from the moment we were brought here in
bondage in 1619 black life in this
country has been defined by hard work
and our labor has generated success
stories that deserve to be celebrated
commonly people refer to the 1619
project as a history but it's not a
history it really is talking about
America today the 1619 project is a
six-part docu-series that explores all
aspects of American life through the
lens of slavery each episode has its own
story arc and has its own particular
beat in history we were told that by
virtue of our bondage we would never be
American but it was by virtue of our
bondage that we became the most American
of all
the very first episode is democracy and
it really talks about how black
Americans has been the primary
democratizing force over Generations in
this country I want to be able to look
back and say I did this so that you
didn't have to that's what Legacy is all
about the race episode deals with the
idea that race is a construct that was
made up to divide the powerful from the
powerless this is a power hierarchy
whether we're talking about where you
live what kind of job you can have and
just in generally how you're valued in
society the music episode is about how
black music is in every aspect of
American life there's a whole cultural
experience that is fascinating and
foreign to white people they are drawn
to this music the capitalism episode
looks at the particular brutality of the
exploitation of Labor I'm looking at the
names of people and their value in the
slave ledgers and they're being listed
literally next to a pig or a cow it's
something I'll never forget
the episode around fear examines the
fear of black men and how that still
plays out today Jefferson was always
worried about the revolution of The
Wheel of Fortune that is we're on top
now but this thing can spin the Justice
episode makes the argument that there is
a great moral and financial debt that is
owed to Black Americans you are calling
for reparations what is the total that
would be old I've seen estimates as high
as 14 trillion dollars that's a big
number it's a big debt though it is a
big debt
I think people are going to be compelled
and surprised and hurt but also Come
Away with a newfound respect for the
role that black Americans have played in
this country
we're still here and we're still
fighting as long as there's life we're
going to have hope
what if America understood after
after the black people have never been
the problem
but the solution
[Music]
foreign